en este vídeo vamos a hablar acerca de
la ecuación del producto interno bruto
que hemos visto con anterioridad para
poder relacionar el ahorro nacional y la
inversión aplicaremos algo de álgebra
para asegurarnos de que coincida con
nuestra intuición otra forma de ver el
pib es que es igual al ingreso nacional
que de notaremos con la letra mayúscula
este ingreso nacional es igual al
consumo más la inversión más el gasto
del gobierno en una economía abierta
también podríamos incluir la exportación
neta pero vamos a enfocarnos en la
economía cerrada donde podemos encontrar
el ahorro vamos a restar el consumo y el
gasto del gobierno en ambos lados de la
ecuación nos va a quedar el ingreso
nacional menos el consumo menos el gasto
del gobierno que es igual a la inversión
de qué otra manera podemos comprender
este lado de la ecuación a nivel
nacional vemos que esto es el ingreso
menos lo que se está consumiendo y esto
es lo que está gastando el gobierno así
que podemos decir que es el ingreso
menos los diferentes tipos de gastos que
hay esto lo podemos ver como el ahorro
con esta igualdad podemos decir que el
ahorro nacional que denotamos con la
letra s mayúscula es igual a la
inversión si les cuesta trabajo
comprender esto piénselo en escala
humana si tomamos nuestros ahorros y los
ponemos en una cuenta de ahorros del
banco el banco va a usar ese dinero para
dar préstamos los cuales se usarán como
inversión y podemos ver esto con más
detalle al considerar los impuestos que
denominamos con la letra t mayúscula
veamos primero la economía privada
tenemos el ingreso nacional menos el
gasto por consumo menos los impuestos
que pagan las personas los impuestos van
al gobierno por lo que permanecen en la
economía nacional vean que no estoy
modificando la ecuación reste impuestos
y sume impuestos finalmente a esto le
restamos el gasto del gobierno y como
estas ecuaciones son equivalentes esto
es igual a la inversión en una economía
cerrada si nos fijamos en esta parte de
la ecuación podemos verla como el ahorro
privado este es el ingreso nacional
menos lo que se consume menos lo que se
paga al gobierno este es el ahorro
privado
esta otra parte de la ecuación esta
sección es lo que el gobierno recibe de
impuestos menos lo que gasta el gobierno
así que podemos ver esto como el ahorro
público en la mayoría de los gobiernos
esta parte es neutral o negativa ya que
el gobierno gasta más de lo que recibe
en impuestos pero podemos ver que esta
parte corresponde al ahorro público
cuando sumamos el ahorro privado más el
ahorro público nos da el ahorro nacional
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo